[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous le voir il ya
des l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la somalie ravagée
depuis près de 30 ans par la guerre
civile
un chaos politique et un désastre
économique
ce pays de la corne d'afrique cherche à
rétablir l'unité de l'état
pourtant ce chemin sera sûrement long
alors pourquoi cette profonde division
interne n'arrive pas à être surmontés en
quoi un pacte hôtel la stabilité de
toute la région le 14 juin 2020 les
présidents de la somalie et du
somaliland se rencontrent à djibouti
pour discuter d'une voie de sortie de ce
conflit civil
plusieurs mesures sont négociées afin de
poursuivre le dialogue
or leur mise en place patine car la
principale pomme de discorde reste
irrésolue c'est l'indépendance du
somaliland
aujourd'hui la somalie est plus que
jamais divisé le pont clan des le
jubaland deux régions qui font partie de
l'état somalien accuse le président du
pis de vouloir faire capoter les
élections législatives prévues pour le
mois de novembre
de son côté le chef de l'état invite les
leaders régionaux au dialogue national à
l'international les régions autonomes
mènent souvent eu ligne bien différente
de celle du gouvernement central ainsi
le président du jubaland s'assure du
soutien du kenya par exemple pour les
élections régionales de 2010 9 contesté
par mogadiscio
le centre le somaliland lui cherche
activement la reconnaissance
internationale et renforce ses liens
avec l'ethiopie le kenya et l'egypte
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur cette étape profondément
divisée depuis les années 90 c'est le
blitz reconnu à l'international l'état
somalien est né en 1962 la fusion de la
somalie italienne et du somaliland
protectorat britannique ayant le statut
de la république fédérale le pays est en
effet composé de six états le somaliland
le pont plante le gall module lire
shabelle l'état du sud-ouest et le jus
ballan à ceci s'ajoute la petite région
de banat dire où se trouve la capitale
mogadiscio mais en réalité le
gouvernement fédéral ne contrôle qu'une
partie du territoire la guerre civile de
1991 a eu comme résultat la proclamation
de l'indépendance du somaliland un des
six états membres
depuis celui-ci dispose de sa propre
constitution d'un gouvernement d'une
armée et même sa propre monnaie or aucun
pays du monde n'a pour le moment reconnu
son indépendance
à la différence du somaliland les 5 et 1
restant se considère comme faisant
partie intégrante de l'état somalien
mais dispose tout de même d'une large
autonomie politique et économique
cependant si l'état du sud ouest le
galmudug élire shabelle coopère
activement avec mogadiscio les deux
autres le jubaland et le complot cherche
à réduire au minimum leur lien avec le
centre fédéral
un signe récent du dégel progressif des
relations entre la somalie et le
somaliland et la rencontre des deux
présidents à djibouti pour dresser les
contours du futur processus de paix une
série de mesures et négocier mais aucune
avancée n'est faite au sujet de
l'indépendance du somaliland principale
pomme de discorde entre les deux
dirigeants le président somalien ainsi
sur l'unité de la somalie qui est
d'ailleurs plus que jamais divisés alors
que le gouvernement fédéral cherche à
trouver un compromis sur les modalités
du scrutin législatif de novembre 2020
deux régions autonomes le ponk landes et
le jubaland refuse toute négociation
elle reproche au président somalien son
soutien à la démission du premier
ministre une décision qui risque de
bouleverser le processus électoral ces
deux régions mènent aussi leur propre
ligne politique
l'international exemple récent le
président du jubaland s'assure du
soutien du kenya pour sa victoire aux
élections régionales alors que celle ci
était contestée par le centre mogadishu
de facto indépendant le somaliland lui
aussi est actif sur l'échiquier mondial
la diplomatie de cet état autoproclamé
cherche à tout prix à obtenir la
reconnaissance internationale pour cela
elle renforce ses liens avec ses
partenaires étrangers à savoir le kenya
par exemple
l'ethiopie l'egypte est même les émirats
arabes unis quelle est donc la stratégie
du gouvernement central à l'étranger
quelles sont les raisons de cette
profonde division de la somalie
enfin quelle est l'ampleur de la crise
humanitaire et sécuritaire qui déchire
le pays pour répondre à ces questions
nous rejoignons marc lavergne
géopolitologue directeur de recherche au
cnrs
monsieur lavergne bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord pensez vous qu'il y ait
encore une chance que le somaliland
soient réintégrés à la somalie un jour
où c'est déjà trop tard
non je pense que dunga qui a déjà trente
ans que le somaliland s'est détaché de
la somalie
ex italienne et qu' il a réussi à
survivre durant toute cette période sans
être reconnu par aucune instance
internationale
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui il n'est
pas question que cette partie de
l'ensemble somalie rejoindre mogadiscio
et donc la république de somalie je
crois que au contraire on voit des
départs de plus en plus vers une
indépendance qui sort est reconnue ou
qui manière pratique fonctionne
aujourd'hui il y à d'autres régions qui
affronte les autorités de mogadiscio le
pont plantes et le joug balante par
exemple pensez vous que la répétition du
scénario somaliland et soit possible
dans leur cas non je crois que les
autorités de dubaï landes au sud de la
somalie et du puntland au nord
non pas l'objectif de se séparer de la
capitale mogadiscio
je pense que leur objectif c'est de tav
et leur autonomie qui est extrêmement
large et qu'il n'est pas contestée
finalement par vos gains initiaux
on le voit actuellement puisque leurs
dirigeants sont à mogadiscio en train de
discuter des modalités de la prochaine
élection présidentielle au niveau
national donc c'est une autonomie qui
correspond si vous voulez à la la façon
dont les somali d'une manière générale
envisage le rapport au pouvoir ce sont
des clans ce sont des tribus qui sont
jalouses de leur autonomie qui ne
veulent pas d'interférence de l'état
central si vous voulez mais qui ne met
pas en cause l'existence d'une d'un pays
qui sèmerait la somalie dans lequel ils
s'intègrent
merci beaucoup monsieur lavernhe nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse mais
nous vous retrouverons en fin d'émission
pour plus de détails sur la question
merci un petit pas vers la paix a
récemment été franchi par la somalie et
le somaliland le 14 juin 2020 les deux
dirigeants se rencontrent en tête à tête
à djibouti pour jeter les bases du futur
processus de paix quatre jours de
négociations qui débouche finalement sur
un communiqué conjoint les deux
délégations affirme avoir adopté un code
de conduite qui guidera à leurs
prochaines négociations
c'est le premier acte viennent ensuite
un engagement à construire la confiance
et la promesse d'appliquer les
précédents accords intergouvernementaux
notamment sur la possibilité pour le
somaliland d'accéder à l'aide
humanitaire internationale
et sur le contre le conjoint de l'espace
aérien pourtant aucune avancée n'est
atteinte au sujet de l'indépendance du
somaliland question centrale des
relations bilatérales sur laquelle
personne ne veut faire de concessions le
fait de reconnaître et de soutenir
l'indépendance du somaliland
contribuerait grandement à panser les
blessures du passé et à permettre à nos
deux états de s'embrasser dans notre
avenir indépendant mais étroitement
imbriqués pour le président somalien il
est hors de question de reconnaître le
sommes
les langues qu'ils considèrent comme
partie intégrante de la fédération
pourtant l'unité du pays se fissure de
plus en plus car en réalité les cinq
états membres restante des pentes très
peu du gouvernement fédéral
ils ont tous leur propre gouvernement
leurs parlements leurs forces armées et
leurs symboles de l'état et si trois
d'entre eux à savoir l'état du sud ouest
le galmudug élire shabelle maintiennent
tout de même la coopération avec le
pouvoir central les deux autres à savoir
le ponk landes et le jubaland essaie de
réduire au minimum leurs liens avec
mogadiscio le jubaland par exemple a vu
ses relations encore plus dégradée avec
le centre en 2019 suite à la tenue des
élections régionales ces résultats
donnés vainqueurs armes est made by
autonomistes et farouche opposant du
pouvoir central
évoquant des irrégularités lors du
scrutin le gouvernement refuse
d'accepter ce résultat et exige de
nouvelles élections s'en suit une longue
escalade entre la capitale et sa région
qui débouchera même sur des
affrontements directs entre leurs armées
respectives le pont plan de lui aussi
entretient des relations difficiles avec
nos gars du chiot depuis la proclamation
de son autonomie en 1998 les autorités
locales reproche au pouvoir central la
mauvaise gestion des ressources
économiques
l'ingérence dans les affaires régionales
l impuissance face aux défis
sécuritaires en février 2020 vient
s'ajouter un nouveau sujet de discorde
entre mogadiscio et ces deux régions
autonomes les élections législatives
prévues pour novembre 2020 tout commence
par le décret présidentiel qui remplace
le système du vote
un direct basé sur les principes
clanique par le suffrage universel
direct
une première depuis 50 ans les régions
boycott
cette initiative qui selon elle crée un
risque de report des élections
même la commission électorale le
confirme le pays n'est pas prêt pour le
scrutin direct sous pression le
président accepte de revoir le modèle
des élections ensemble avec les
responsables régionaux le 21 août trois
d'entre eux
le maire de mogadiscio et le président
du pis parviennent à un accord
des délégués de chaque circonscription
régionale choisir ont chacun un membre
du parlement et à leur tour les élus
choisiront le président du pays mais les
dirigeants du puntland et du jubaland
quant à eux n'assiste pas au dernier
round des négociations et ne
reconnaissent pas ce compromis
électorale pourquoi et bien parce qu'ils
accusent le président du pays de vouloir
entraver le processus électoral pour
preuve il cite la démission récente du
premier ministre somalien
hassan aliker un des principaux
responsables de l'organisation des
élections
fin juillet la décision est initiée par
le parlement et soutenu par le président
somalien le poste de premier ministre
est depuis toujours vacant il reste donc
à savoir si le pouvoir central arrivera
à s'entendre avec les deux régions sur
les modalités du scrutin alors que le
débat continue sur ce sujet épineux
le pays s'enfonce dans une crise
humanitaire d'une ampleur inouïe
plus d'un tiers de la population a
besoin d'une aide humanitaire urgente la
plupart d'entre eux sont victimes d'une
terrible famine qui tourmente le pays
depuis 2011
la situation s'aggrave avec la pandémie
de kobe 19 qui a lourdement frappé
l'économie du pays déjà au bord du
gouffre près de sept personnes sur dix
vivent avec moins de un dollar 90 par
jour
les deux tiers des jeunes sont au
chômage chaos politique crise économique
et humanitaire les conditions sont plus
que favorables à l'activité terroriste
qui ne cesse de progresser
il s'agit avant tout du groupe jihadiste
al chabaab liés à al qaïda
ford - 7000 âmes il contrôle aujourd'hui
de vastes territoires dans les régions
rurales du sud et du centre de la
somalie des zones où les terroristes se
déplacent librement prélèvent des taxes
recrute de nouveaux membres et préparent
des attaques plus de 4000 civils ont été
tués par les shabab depuis 2010
face à cette menace le gouvernement
somalien mobilise ses ressources et
mènent régulièrement des opérations
antiterroristes
ces efforts suffiront ils pour combattre
les islamistes sachant qu'une aide
militaire étrangère est prêté aux pays
plus de vingt mille soldats africains
sont actuellement prêts
en somalie dans le cadre de la mission
de l'union africaine celle ci est
largement soutenu par les états unis qui
mènent des frappes aériennes contre les
djihadistes en 2019
il bat d'ailleurs en record soixante
trois raids en une année selon amnesty
international ces frappes ont fait des
dizaines de morts parmi les civils
sans pour autant aboutir à de grandes
avancées le mandat de cette mission
expire en 2021 mille soldats ont déjà
été retirés en mars
quel est donc l'avenir de la lutte anti
terroriste en somalie
quel intérêt les voisins ce malien
poursuivent-t-ils dans ce pays la
réponse après la pause
[Musique]
depuis près de 30 ans la somalie est
ravagée par la guerre civile d'une
violence inouïe médiation de ses voisins
se met rencontre entre les parties du
conflit
rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter ce
conflit c'est en 1960 que la république
de somalie voit le jour née d'une fusion
entre la somalie britannique au nord et
italienne au sud
aden abdullah haussmann d'art est élu
président de ce nouvel état
son mandat de 1960 à 1967 est marquée
par des luttes claniques incessantes et
des conflits avec les pays voisins
la cause les prétentions somaliennes sur
des régions transfrontalières peuplée de
somali tel qu l'ogaden éthiopiens en
1967 l'ancien premier ministre habib
rachid ali sharmarke est élu président
mais il est tué deux ans plus tard lors
d'un attentat à ce moment là le général
mohamed siad barre s'empare du pouvoir
après un coup d'état militaire
il instaure un gouvernement de type
socialiste interdite le multipartisme et
veut mettre fin aux luttes claniques
ils s'engagent à relever l'économie du
pays en nationalisant les entreprises
étrangères et résultats ne sont pourtant
pas au rendez vous fidèle à l'idée de
grandes somalie ils attaquent en 1977
l'ethiopie afin de lui arracher la
région de l'ogaden
l'offensive se solde par un échec
cuisant affaibli par le conflit sur le
plan économique et militaire la somalie
fait face à la résurgence des tensions
clanique le gouvernement les répriment
violemment renforçant le mécontentement
tribal contesté siad barré renversé en
1991 par des forces rebelles et se
réfugier au kenya
privée de gouvernement central le pays
plonge dans une lutte de pouvoir entre
seigneurs de guerre et divers clans
somaliens
au même moment le pays est frappé par la
sécheresse qui provoque une famine
meurtrière plus de 300000 morts
l'unité du pays commence à se fissurer
toujours en 1991 l'ancien territoire
britannique au nord proclame son
indépendance
il prend le nom de somaliland et
instaure un nouveau système politique
basé sur la loi clanique
il reste pourtant non reconnue par la
communauté internationale face à ce
chaos politique et humanitaire l'onu
envoie ses casques bleus dans le pays en
l'intervention des états unis suivra un
an plus tard leur présence sur le sol
somalien offre un certain calme au pays
mais les violences reprennent de plus
belle après leur départ en 1994 et 1995
le premier pas majeur dans la paix est
franchie en 2000 une conférence de paix
organise à djibouti regroupant les
principaux clans du pays à la suite de
la rencontre le gouvernement national de
transition et forme et or privés de
ressources est déchirée par les
désaccords internes
le nouvel organe échoué à imposer son
pouvoir sur l'ensemble du territoire
somalien
en 2003 son mandat expire est l'organe
est dissous l'année suivante c'est la
nouvelle tentative à la suite de la
conférence de paix à nairobi un
gouvernement fédéral de transition voit
le jour
l'organe reste toutefois implanté au
kenya pour des raisons de sécurité
ce n'est qu'en décembre 2006 que le
gouvernement s'installe en somalie et
reprend le contrôle de mogadiscio
grâce à l'aide de l'armée éthiopienne en
2012 le mandat du gft prend fin afin
d'éviter l'impasse politique les
dirigeants fédéraux et régionaux
somaliens s'accorde sur le redémarrage
du système politique somalien par
l'adoption d'une constitution le premier
round son texte est approuvé par
l'assemblée nationale constituante
s'en suit l'élection présidentielle au
suffrage indirect qui donnent vainqueur
hassan cheikh mohamoud
promettant la paix la stabilité aux
somaliens ils échouent à remplir ses
engagements
en fait en 2016 mogadicio exerce son
pouvoir sur une partie très limitée du
territoire somalien en 2017 mohamed
abdullahi mohamed est élu à la tête du
pays prenant toujours une plus grande
unité du pays et une lutte plus active
contre le terrorisme
mais pour l'instant son bilan est mitigé
d'un côté il essaye de redresser le pays
en initiant les réformes économiques et
de défense de l'autre la situation
sécuritaire reste très alarmante
alors que l'unité du pays se fissure de
plus en plus soixante ans après son
indépendance
la somalie est un triste exemple d'états
défaillants qu'aucune intervention
internationale n'a pu remettre sur pied
pire encore l' ingérence externe n'a
parfois fait qu'envenimer des crises
déjà aigu comme dans le cas de
l'intervention kényane voisins du sud
qui a joué cette année un rôle
contestable ou tour des élections
régionales du jubaland en effet en ou
2019 le jubaland annonce les résultats
de ces élections régionales mais
mogadiscio la capitale refuse
catégoriquement de les reconnaître
c'est alors que débute une longue
escalade entre le centre et la région du
jubaland qui en vient jusqu aux
affrontements en mars 2020 les combats
se déroulent près de la frontière avec
le kenya et ce dernier saisit donc
l'occasion pour soutenir son allié le
président élu du jubaland armes est ma
de bête de plus le puissant voisin
accuse mogadiscio d'avoir un pied tu es
sur son territoire cette crise interne
prend du coup des allures de conflit
international
dépassé par ces événements le
gouvernement somalien et forcé
d'obtempérer il retire ses troupes
puis reconnaît en juin dernier la
légitimité de made by oj du ballon entre
temps encouragé par le revers essuyé par
mogadiscio le kenya ne tarde pas de
repasser à l'offensive cette fois sur le
champ diplomatique en juillet une autre
délégation kenyane via un visite au
somaliland
ces diplomates promettent des
investissements et flirte même avec la
possibilité de reconnaître l'état de
somaliland haut
grand dam de mogadishio évidemment la
capitale s'insurge contre tous contacts
diplomatiques avec cette région de peur
de voir son autorité s'affaiblir le
kenya n'est d'ailleurs pas le seul à
s'intéresser au somaliland à ce jour
ambitieuse la région à d'abord fait
parler d'elle en reconnaissant taiwan et
accueille désormais une délégation de
l'egypte ainsi un allié du gouvernement
de mogadiscio le caire cherchent
désormais les faveurs du somaliland et
lui propose d'accueillir sa base
militaire
alors pourquoi un tel changement de la
part de l'egypte ce qui est certain
c'est que ces manoeuvres ne sont pas du
tout du goût d'un autre voisin
l'ethiopie nous espérons que ça ne se
fera pas au détriment de l'ethiopie ou
d'autres pays voisins
car ça serait illégal et contraire à la
paix et la sécurité internationales on
le voit l'ethiopie est inquiète pourquoi
c'est qu'au centre de ces jeux
d'influencé régionaux se trouve le
barrage que les tupi construit sur le
nil
or si ce projet était mené jusqu'au bout
et leur et le potentiel de priver
l'egypte de l'essentiel de ses
ressources en eau problème pour le caire
exceptionnellement le gouvernement
central somalien ain allier pourtant
historique a choisi cette fois ci de
laisser faire le projet de barrage
du coup l'egypte boudent mogadiscio et
tourner ses faveurs vers le sommet
l'élan mais dans cette affaire les tupi
pourrait bien se dresser à nouveau en
travers des intérêts de l'egypte en
effet l'ethiopie s'intéresse beaucoup
aux ports somaliland et de berbera pays
enclavé et prospère elle a besoin de
débouchés maritimes pour desservir les
marchandises le port de berbera est une
alternative idéale à djibouti l'éthiopie
utilisé jusqu'à présent pour rénover les
infrastructures de berbères à l'ethiopie
recherche de nouveaux investisseurs en
2016 elle convainc les émirats arabes
unis de louer le port de berbera il est
alors cédé à l'emirati deep in world
avec départ pour le somaliland et
l'ethiopie elle-même leur ambition est
d'en faire une véritable plaque
tournante du commerce et des transports
dans la corne de l'afrique
l'ethiopie et redirige petit à petit son
trafic commercial
et ambitionne d'atteindre 30% vers 2023
bien entendu le somaliland en profite
également
car le nouveau barbera donne une
nouvelle impulsion à l'économie du pays
pourtant les succès du somaliland ne
font pas pour autant la joie de
mogadishu à mesure que la région
multiplie les contrats la colère de la
capitale montrent la société dip world
nous a offensé a compromis l'unité de
notre pays et n'arrête pas de s'ingérer
nous avons été patients mais la patience
a des limites
mais ces attaques n'ont aucun effet sur
la région insoumise ou sur ses nouveaux
alliés puissants parmi eux les émirats
arabes unis trouvent un somalie un
terrain fertile pour leur investissement
et multiplie les initiatives
par exemple en matière de défense
récemment il lance la construction d'une
base aéronavale à haber berra et
modernise deux aéroports locaux
de plus toujours à berbera l'argent
émirati finance tout un éventail de
grands projets d'infrastructures s'y
ajoutent deux nouveaux centres
d'intérêts au puntland
les emiratis décroche le port de
bossasso et au jubaland une autre grande
acquisition serait préparée cependant il
est intéressant de noter que ces grandes
manoeuvres des émirats sont plutôt
réalisés dans les régions
indépendantistes ou autonomistes
pourquoi et bien parce que depuis mars
2018 toute activité de dp world est
interdite dans ce mali par le
gouvernement central or cette société
gère la plupart des actifs émirati dans
le pays mais mogadicio accuse le groupe
d'atteinte à la souveraineté et à
l'unité somalienne la réponse émirati ne
se fait pas attendre
leur mission d'entraînement pour les
troupes somaliennes active depuis 2015
et fermés de même que l'hôpital gratuits
qu'ils finançaient dans la capitale
somalienne en disgrâce à mogadiscio abou
dhabi garde ses investissements mais
perd l'espoir d'un appui sur la scène
internationale de son côté la somalie
peut compter sur le soutien d'un autre
allié dans le golfe l'arabie saoudite
dès 2015 le nouveau prince héritier
mohammed bin salman cherche de nouveaux
alliés et tourne son regard vers ce pays
africain islamique sa campagne de
séduction commence par un succès
en janvier 2016 la somalie roncq toute
relation avec le rival de l'arabie
saoudite et l'iran le même jour et
l'obtient 50 millions de dollars dette
de la part de ryad
pourtant cette stratégie tourne vite à
l'échec en 2017 alors que l'arabie
saoudite déclare un blocus diplomatiques
et économiques du qatar elle octroie une
nouvelle aide généreuse à mogadiscio
mais cette fois la somalie refuse cette
aide et refusent aussi nette de rompre
avec doit son allié de longue date
en effet en s'intéressant maintenant à
la somalie l'arabie saoudite arrive déjà
trop tard pour y faire la loi
le qatar est aux côtés du gouvernement
de mogadiscio depuis son élection de
2012 et son soutien sonnant et
trébuchant
ce chiffre déjà à 4 milliards de dollars
de plus ce drame n'est pas le seul allié
somaliens qui hérite le golfe car il ya
aussi la turquie qui est très bien
implanté en 2011 le président turc
erdogan et le premier chef d'état non
africains à visiter mogadiscio depuis
près de 20 ans les turcs à la somalie
elle commence encore plus tôt avec près
d'un milliard de dollars en aide
humanitaire et un commerce bilatéral
fleurissant le volet économique est
complété par une assistance militaire
d'envergure
la somalie accueille dès 2010 est la
plus grande base militaire turque à
l'étranger qui sert de centre
d'entraînement pour les troupes locales
une confiance absolue dont profitent les
deux parties en 2020 mogadishio ouvre
l'exploration du pétrole de sociétés
étrangères et invite immédiatement la
turquie avec des positions fermes ankara
et doit pourront-ils compter sur la
stabilité des institutions somaliennes
comment sortir de la fragmentation au
sein du pays la percée indépendantiste
du somaliland
at elle des chances d'aboutir pour mieux
comprendre tout ça nous revenons vers
marc lavergne jeu ou politologue et
directeur de recherche au cnrs
monsieur lavernhe parlons maintenant de
l'aspect géopolitique du conflit
somalien
pourquoi certains pays comme l'egypte ou
les émirats arabes unis préfèrent
aujourd'hui de coopérer avec le sommet
les landes
non reconnus au lieu de la somalie mais
certainement les émirats arabes unis
cherchent à contrôler l'entrée de la mer
rouge
donc ils sont actuellement en opération
au sud yémen et de l'autre côté du golfe
d'aden
il y a les rivages du somaliland et
alors il ya d'une part la volonté de
contrôler des ports donc il ya des
accords qui ont été passés entre la
grande compagnie dit power d'un dubaï
port world pour remettre en état
c'est pour ce malien en particulier le
port de berbera qui était occupée par
l'union soviétique et qui était une base
militaire mais qui aujourd'hui est assez
dégradé et qui est la porte du plateaux
éthiopiens
c'est à dire que derrière la contrôle de
ces rivages le port de berbera et puis
aussi le port de bossasso puntland
l'idée c'est de dax et d addis abeba à
l'ethiopie à ces 100 millions
d'habitants de l'ethiopie qui sont en
plein développement avec des ressources
énergétiques
avec une main-d'oeuvre opérationnel
la chine est très présente en ethiopie
pour accéder à toutes ces richesses et
les émirats arabes unis s'inscrivent un
peu dans ces routes de la soie qui sont
prônées par les chinois et jouent aussi
leur propre carte c'est à dire que il
chercha à préparer l'après pétrole à
sortir du golfe persique de ce face à
face avec l'iran en acquérant des
positions encore une forme
ollier men et puis à l'entrée du golfe
d'aden qui est quand même une des
principales artères maritime mondial si
vous pouvez répondre très brièvement à
la dernière question pourquoi selon vous
somalie n'a toujours pas obtenu de paix
depuis les années 1990 se voit qu'il ya
un peu comment dire une méconnaissance
du tissu social somalie les somalie que
ce soit dans les pays dont on parle là
mais aussi en ethiopie ou au kenya sont
organisés en clans
ils sont malgré le fait qu'il parle la
même langue qu'ils ont la même religion
la même culture
le même mode de vie eh bien ce sont des
gens qui n'ont pas un rapport à l'état
extrêmement confiants et extrêmement je
dire ce sont des taux qui se battent
entre eux pour l'accès ou pas de fra aux
points d'eau autre ressource la
piraterie etc
donc voilà je crois que tout simplement
c'est un état qui est en situation
permanente d'instabilité
merci beaucoup monsieur lavergne je
rappelle marc lavergne géopolitologue
directeur de recherche au cnrs et était
aujourd'hui avec nous merci encore
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage cette
partie là n'est pas encore terminée la
semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
vous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]